[Musique]
Michel seoget José Legault Raphaël Jacob
bonsoir
tour de table évidemment un sujet
incontournable sur les accusations 34
chefs d'accusation contre Monsieur Trump
ça va être intéressant à suivre pour
certains déjà je disais des experts ça
sera pas évident en cours première
impression Michel C
parce que pour la salle de bonnes
raisons que acheter le silence de
quelqu'un en la loi américaine n'est pas
une offense criminelle alors tout
découle de l'année il faut trouver moyen
en achetant le silence
en même temps ça risque de nuire
monsieur Trump quand même pour toutes
sortes de raisons d'abord il est obligé
d'admettre des frères secrets congel
avec les électeurs évangéliques ce sera
pas exactement la chose qui vous lisez
Trump qui dit à son avocat
l'une des deux femmes avec qui il y a eu
des relations qui sont conjugales écoute
essaye de la payer le plus tard possible
après l'élection de refuser d'argent ce
que si on se rend là
en vrai personnage qui sort de là ça
sera pas très joli légalement moi je me
fais beaucoup métro
sur la terre qui a dit écoutez si c'est
ça la cause là ça passera pas le test de
tribunaux c'est pas la meilleure cause
la meilleure c'est celle de la Géorgie
qui va venir probablement plus tard mais
c'est un début restons sur celle-là mais
effectivement il y en a d'autres plus
fondamental dans
mais quand même José
oui c'est ça je pense que là on est en
train de créer un espèce de suspense ou
d'attente pour justement quoi que bon
moi je suis pas une experte en matière
juridique je sais pas du tout comment ça
va se passer
en cours tout ça et c'est pas demain
matin la veille non plus mais sur le
plan politique strictement je pense que
ce à quoi on assiste c'est cette espèce
de
dentêtement de Donald Trump même lorsque
il est accusé de perdurer dans le
paysage politique américain avec tout ce
que ça suppose avec toute sa base
électorale qui est encore en attente etc
le dommage que ça fait aussi aux parties
républicains que ça continue de faire et
la polarisation que ça continue à
alimenter dans la société américaine
donc c'est ça c'est cette page là qu'on
n'est pas capable de tourner et c'est
comme dans le film Le Parrain quand il
dit je pensais que je suis à l'extérieur
Raphaël tout à l'heure j'ai dit dans
l'émission que vous étiez vous
commenciez avec nous j'ai une
renaissance de cette cause là le faire
renaître il devance tous ces
concurrents pour le pour le parti
républicain écouter c'est pas simplement
Patrice qui l'est devant c'est que son
avance a doublé sinon triplé dépendant
qu’elles sont l'âge qu'elle ferme de
sondage vous regardez entre le moment où
on attendait l'incubation et le moment à
la vers la fin la semaine dernière où
elle était finalement annoncée donc
certainement que ça le SERT et ce qui
sert de notre chambre présentement au
sein du parti républicain et on voit
d'ailleurs un des sondages très récents
qui ont été menés écoutez une avance de
quoi 30 presque 35 points de pourcentage
sur monsieur De Santis qui sont
éventuels probables plus important
rival c'est pas compliqué Patrice à se
staffie des primaires ce statut du
siècle électoral il y a jamais eu depuis
le début du système des primaires
modernes en 1972 ce soit du côté
démocrate aux républicains quelqu'un qui
était dans une telle position d'avance
et qui n'a pas au final été le candidat
retenu pour représenter le parti donc
c'est pas une garantie mais il est
massivement aidé par ça et rapidement ce
que j'allais dire c'est que ce qui aide
à notre champ présentement au sein du
parti républicain nuit au parti
républicain dans une perspective
d'élection générale parce qu'il demeure
et de loin le candidat que les
démocrates monsieur Biden le premier
voudrait le plus affronter en novembre
2024 voilà toutes les renie Michel je
vous vois chez José c'est qu'un court
terme ça laisse à l'aide pour prendre le
parti mais en ça ça nuit aux
républicains parce que Biden devant
Trump a plus de chance que devant de
sainteté sous quelqu'un d'autre Michel
entre ça dépend du sondage entre 60 et
70% des acteurs indépendants donc ceux
qu'on a dont on a besoin dans une
élection pas des déjà convaincue
d'avance qui disent oui c'est normal
qu'il a été accusé alors ça nous
donnerait à peu près le même résultat
que la dernière fois c'est à dire un
pays très divisé mais
7 millions de vote il faut quand même
pas l'oublier là
le meilleur ennemi de base le meilleur
ami de Biden c'est dans un club très
bien je dis très bien parce que je vais
dire au revoir à Raphaël surtout au
Téléjournal Raphaël la journée a fini
mais pour le panel
je je demande que verra bien voilà c'est
magique Véronique rebonsoir
écoutons parce que là oui c'était la
bonne entente on avait connu ça il y a
quelques temps Trudeau le goût
aujourd'hui
je parle toujours des petits oiseaux
quand je vois ces scènes là on écoute
deux extraits c'était à la dévie à Lévy
annonce importante pour ce chantier là
c'est c'est énorme comme impact on
écoute on revient
vous savez quand Steven Harper a lancé
la stratégie nationale de construction
navale en 2010
il a exclu le chantier Davy mais notre
gouvernement travaille depuis 2015 mains
dans la main avec le gouvernement du
Québec pour livrer la marchandise
quelque chose que les politiciens
conservateurs n'avaient pas la volonté
de faire
là je vais vous parler un peu de Justin
Trudeau
vous savez c'est pas toujours d'accord
avec Justin quand je suis pas d'accord
je le dis mais quand je suis d'accord je
veux le dire aussi la fois est fait
merci d'avoir réglé ce dossier avec
Monsieur Biden Justin merci beaucoup
merci Justin d'avoir mis en place ce
programme-là merci c'est gagnant gagnant
gagnant pour tout le monde donc quel
beau dire
et François Philippe
on le sait et compta
dévie les compta monsieur Trudeau vous
avez remarqué comme en campagne écorche
un peu qui avait qui n'avait pas inclus
la dévie dans la stratégie fédérale José
Legault on est loin de la conférence de
presse ou monsieur Legault avait dit
voté conservateur
oui surtout ne votez pas libéral c'est
surtout c'est ce qu'il avait dit ne
votez pas pour les libéraux
c'est écouter c'est sûr que la politique
comme disent les Anglais pour le texte
mixte ça peut faire des drôles des
drôles d'alliance mais en même temps je
regardais ça ce matin et j'avais
l'impression d'être à la veille d'une
campagne électorale de quelqu'un à
quelque part mais bon évidemment on sait
que Monsieur Justin Trudeau n'ira pas en
élections tout de suite mais pour Justin
Trudeau c'est un coup-fumeur sur
plusieurs tableaux principalement
évidemment auprès de l'électeur
québécois parce que c'est une annonce
qui est très importante pour la grande
région de Québec c'est vraiment majeur
et en même temps en effet croquant
jambes au conservateur parce Steven
Harper interposé donc ça c'est pour rien
pour François Legault ben évidemment
c'est
c'est on voit un Premier ministre qui
assume pleinement sont son abandon de
l'option souverainiste lorsqu'il a créé
la CAQ et qui lorsqu'il est temps de
jouer le jeu du généraliste mais tout à
fait à l'aise à le jouer je sais pas
comment ça va ça va se jouer chez les
nombreux expéquistes qui sont à la CAQ
là peut-être que ce matin c'était
peut-être un petit peu difficile à
prendre mais ça c'est très clair alors
pour les gens qui pensent que François
Legault est encore souvenu dans le
placard qui prépare un référendum Zoop
et qui va se passer fort fort
c'est c'est je pense que on voit que
François Legault assume
[Musique]
ses habits nationalistes tirer
fédéraliste quand c'est bon comme il dit
Michel C il va le dire il va pas se
gêner pour féliciter son partenaire
parce qu'une annonce Québec investit
pour moderniser l'usine et le fédéral
envoie des gros contrôles c'est un tango
c'était parce qu'elle appartenait à ce
moment-là une compagnie qui n'a pas les
rétrés solides basé à Monaco à la
difficulté alors il y avait quand même
des raisons mais là il y avait plus de
raison justement alors c'est quelque
chose qui devait être fait et c'est du
gros argent pour la région de Québec
même s'ils ont pas tous les contrats des
9 briselas qui s'en viennent c'est
énorme alors on peut juste on peut juste
se réjouir de ça pour la région Québec
plutôt pour tout le Québec aussi non
mais tout à fait c'est une richesse de
construire des navires c'est une grande
richesse et Monsieur Trudeau même dans
son envolée aujourd'hui parce que
c'était des envolés vous avez raison
José ça ressemblait à un début de
campagne a dit puis on va en construire
pour d'autres une expertise alors mais
revenons à la grande région de Québec
Véronique pour monsieur Legault c'était
plus plus des deux côtés là absolument
parce que les retombées économiques sont
très importantes non seulement pour le
Canada pour la région mais effectivement
pour la réussite de Québec cours parce
qu'avec le télétravail vous avez par
exemple des jardins là-bas ou qui est un
gros gros employeur mais il y a de plus
en plus de gens qui sont en télétravail
donc le fait d'avoir des travailleurs
comme ça sur un horizon 20 ans ça va
permettre une vitalité économique très
importante à cette région là puis
j'écoutais mes deux collègues moi je
veux juste vous dire une chose par
contre monsieur Legault a l'amour
fédéral infidèle alors peut-être que là
il s'entend bien avec Monsieur Trudeau
mais il va toujours aller au plus
offrant il est infidèle en matière
d'amour fédérale je dirais mais quand ça
concerne des questions économiques et
que juste introdo est prêt à allonger
l'argent des gros montants à ce moment
là c'est toujours justement
l'amour fou parce qu'on le vit aussi
pour l'Internet au vitesse on le voit
pour la filière batterie et c'est quand
ce sont des questions
identitaires en lien avec l'immigration
ou alors quand on joue dans les
juridictions provinciales fédérales ou
là ça marche pas du tout on l'a vu
d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours au
niveau des soins dentaires donc je
voudrais que c'est un amour très
variable et on cache par ça
José vous aviez dit
non non mais ça allait dire que bon
évidemment comme dans tout couple
politique c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir des
chicanes une fois de temps en temps mais
c'est mais c'est sur le mot politique
mais c'est clair que
lorsqu'il y a un désaccord on le vu même
avec les transferts en santé qui étaient
très très décevant ça a pas pris de
temps que Monsieur le goût décidé de
passer à un autre appel
presque le jour même la conférence de
presse il était pas si fâché OK
il y a peut-être un sujet qui peut faire
des flammèches entre les deux je vais
commencer avec vous mais avant on va
écouter comme des extraits sur le
troisième lien parce que on était dans
la région peut-être il y a des
travailleurs-là qui ont des véhicules
peut-être que ils vont droit y aller en
tramway même notre collègue disait que
la nouvelle mouture du troisième lien il
y aurait un tuyau au milieu pour le
tramway donc transport en commun donc
financement du fédéral on écoute on
revient
on a fait de faire des nouvelles études
achalandage incluant
les impacts du télétravail donc qui est
diminue la capacité d'ici quelques
semaines Geneviève Guilbaud va faire une
proposition puis on ne peut rien ajouter
pour l'instant et comme toujours on a
hâte de voir la proposition on va
travailler ensemble je pense que les
gens ont commencé à comprendre à quel
point nos deux gouvernements travaillent
bien ensemble pour
extraordinaire même sur le troisième
lien Véronique tu trouvais oui
envoyez-moi votre dessin peut-être on va
trouver alors c'était les petits oiseaux
là Véronique il y a des conditions quand
même le gouvernement du transport
collectif c'est cette portion-là qui est
prêt à financer effectivement et
peut-être que ça force justement Québec
en ce moment à revoir ses plans le
troisième lien je vous rappelle que
c'était une promesse électorale fort de
2018 tout comme ça l'était pour les
maternelles 4 ans des maternelles 4 ans
on s'est servi du prétexte de la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre et du manque de locaux
pour repousser ce projet-là le
gouvernement aurait pu se servir du
prétexte de la pandémie du télétravail
mais ne le fait pas visiblement parce
qu'il continue d'injecter de l'argent
dans des études et plus on attend avant
de dévoiler ses études-là plus ils sont
plus on laisse aller le débat public
plus ça donne l'impression effectivement
qu'il veut le réaliser encore ce
projet-là puis moi dans les mes
conversations avec par exemple des
sources gouvernementales des ministres
des députés j'essaie de savoir est-ce
qu'en coulisses effectivement vous
voulez encore le faire ou pas ce
projet-là puis à chaque fois on me dit
oui c'est sûr qu'on va le faire parce
que peut-être que de reculer
politiquement ça ferait trop mal puis en
fait j'ai quand même l'impression encore
qu'ils y croient vraiment c'est juste
que pour aller chercher de l'argent du
gouvernement fédéral pour avoir pour
aller chercher l'appui du maire marchand
il faut inclure plus de transport
collectif on modifie le dessin
j'osais mon croit encore car un dessin
enfin 48
la quatrième mouture c'est ça bon il y a
eu aussi un changement c'est que il y a
une ministre des Transports qui
s'appelle Geneviève quipo donc on
imagine qu'elle joue un rôle
aussi important maintenant dans le
dossier et on connaît le côté
opérationnel
donc ça aussi ça peut ça peut ça peut
changer quelque chose mais c'est clair
que
j'oserais pas utiliser le mot
improvisation le mais quand même on sait
si on voit d'une version à une autre à
une autre peut-être la volonté politique
reste mais on reste quand même encore
relativement dans le flou il y a encore
un gros point d'interrogation Michel C
sur le on attend les là justement vous
avez parlé de la ministre Guilbaud elle
nous a dit
elle début de l'année ça peut être
considéré comme plusieurs mois alors on
verra mais on attendait quelques
semaines de quelques semaines et souvent
utilisés
et le gouvernement principal employeur
de la région de Québec alors si il
décide que le télétravail c'est pas si
mauvais que ça l'endage va
convaincu que ça se prend pour une
troisième bien pour un bien raison bien
simple c'est que ça va coûter trop cher
à la fois et on veut avoir l'argent du
fédéral là on va dire les tuyaux on va
faire du transport en commun les fédéral
n'est pas obligé de payer pour plus que
la partie transport en commun est-ce que
ce sera suffisant à ce moment-là pour
que ce soit intéressant moi ce que je
vois c'est bon troisième lien était dans
le plan d'investissement des transports
de la région se dira balache l'année
passée il n'est pas là cette année ça
c'est des signes ça aussi alors moi je
suis pas trop sûr que le gouvernement
fait pas un baroud honneur pour dire on
a fait un nouveau projet fédéral veut
toujours pas il faut sûr qu'à la fin ils
vont le faire très bien merci beaucoup à
vous trois à bientôt bonne soirée au
revoir